When the green and blue uniformed athletes
of the University of Notre Dame run on to
the field or court, their fans are rooting
for the “Fighting Irish.”
Represented by a small green leprechaun- hat
tilted with his fists up, ready to fight-
the athletic teams of this South Bend, Indiana
Catholic school have been playing under this
moniker for, officially, 87 years.
But here’s the thing: the school was actually
founded by French Catholic priests, not Irish
Catholics.
So, how did Notre Dame become the “Fighting
Irish?”
Shouldn’t they be called the “Fighting
French?”
In November 1842, eight members of the newly-established
Congregation of Holy Cross, based in a small
village outside of Le Mans, France, were given
524 acres of land by the Bishop of Vincennes
in the, at the time, 35-year-old state of
Indiana.
Within two years, they had established a school
on the land.
A 29-year-old French priest, Edward Sorin,
named the school “L’Université de Notre
Dame du Lac,” or the “University of Our
Lady of the Lake.”
The school was Catholic and all-male (and
would stay that way for 128 years, until 1972
when it became coed).
In 1879, a fire destroyed the Main Building.
Always a religious man, Sorin said,
I came here as a young man and dreamed of
building a great university in honor of Our
Lady.
But I built it too small, and she had to burn
it to the ground to make the point.
So, tomorrow, as soon as the bricks cool,
we will rebuild it, bigger and better than
ever.
And they did rebuild, indeed making the school
bigger and better than before as was vowed.
Less than a decade later, in 1887, the athletic
department even established a football team.
The game of (American) football has its origins
in rugby, first played in English public schools
during the mid-19th century.
The rules and how the game was played varied
from place to place, but when the game made
its way over to America, it developed into
something a little different.
Many historians believe that American football
can be traced back to a game played between
Rutgers University and Princeton in 1869.
Using modified London Football Association
rules, the game quickly took off among eastern
colleges.
In 1876, Walter Camp, a Yale grad and coach
who would become known as the “Father of
American Football,” proposed a line of scrimmage,
as well as down and distance rules, forever
separating it from rugby.
The game expanded very quickly, gaining favor
on the east coast all the way to the Midwest.
In 1880, there were only eight universities
that fielded collegiate football teams.
By the turn of the century, there were 43.
One of those was Notre Dame.
On November 23, 1887, Notre Dame and Michigan
matched up.
127 years later, their rivalry is still going.
On that November day, Michigan won eight to
zero, though as the Scholastic, the University’s
student magazine, pointed out, it was never
meant to be a particularly competitive game:
It was not considered a match contest, as
the home team had been organized only a few
weeks, and the Michigan boys, the champions
of the West, came more to instruct them in
the points of the Rugby game than to win fresh
laurels.
Over the next twelve seasons, the Notre Dame
football team compiled a 25-11-3 record against
the other intercollegiate teams under the
nickname the “Catholics.”
Many of these other college teams they beat
were also Catholic schools- Boston College,
Fordham, and Holy Cross just to name a few.
As opposed to Notre Dame’s French background,
they were founded by, and intended for, recently
immigrated Irish Catholics.
The Irish Potato Famine of 1845 convinced
many to make their way across the Atlantic
to America.
As they settled in eastern cities, they desired
a place for, or at least to aspire to, a higher
education.
These colleges represented upward mobility
and the ability for anyone to make it in America.
As recent immigrants to this country, the
view of the Irish were colored by pretty jingoistic
views.
They were known as drunks and “brutes,”
while possessing a violent temper.
Even future President Theodore Roosevelt,
while a New York State Assembly Member, had
some choice words to say about the Irish,
“The average Catholic Irishman of the first
generation, as represented in the Assembly
[is a] low, venal, corrupt, and unintelligent
brute.”
To call someone Irish was to imply that they
were uncivilized, violent, and un-American.
In other words, it was an insult.
So this brings us to the nickname.
It seems that not even the University itself
is exactly sure how this rather odd nickname
came to be, though there are some popular
theories and with the documented evidence
at hand we can mostly piece together in general
how it came to be.
To start, one legend states it was 1899 when,
during the second half of a game between Notre
Dame and Northwestern with Notre Dame leading
five to nothing in Evanston, Illinois, the
fans started chanting “Kill the Fighting
Irish, Kill the Fighting Irish.”
Whether they failed to realize that Notre
Dame was French Catholic or simply just didn’t
care and were looking for a choice insult,
it didn’t matter.
The nickname supposedly stuck from there.
Another story, albeit a much kinder representation
of the nickname, goes that the name came from
the Union Army’s Fighting Irish 69th Regiment.
Part of the larger Irish Brigade, they fought
with valor, bravery, and were brutally effective.
They went into every battle with their colorfully
designed green battle flag.
Legend has it that when President Lincoln
paid them a visit, he picked up a corner of
the green Irish flag, kissed it, and said,
“God bless the Irish flag.”
So, when the press saw these Notre Dame football
players play with toughness, courage, and
assuming they were also Irish, the nickname
that once belonged to the beloved 69th Regiment
was given.
Yet another theory of how the nickname came
to be, this one with at least a tiny bit of
documented evidence, was from a game featuring
Notre Dame and Michigan in 1909.
With Notre Dame trailing at the half to their
rivals, a player turned to some of his “Irish”
teammates (or at least had Irish names like
Dolan, Kelly, Glynn, and Duffy) and yelled
“”What’s the matter with you guys?
You’re all Irish and you’re not fighting
worth a lick.”
The team went on to win the game eleven to
three and the press attributed the victory
to the “Fighting Irish.”
After this 1909 match, Sportswriter E.A.
Batchelor, supposedly having overheard the
aforementioned exchange, published an article
in the Detroit Free Press titled, “‘Shorty’
Longman’s Fighting Irishmen Humble the Wolverines
to Tune of 11 to 3,” giving us the first
known documented evidence of the team being
called by this nickname.
He went on to write,
Eleven Fighting Irishman wrecked the Yost
machine this afternoon.
Three sons of Erin, individually and collectively
representing the University of Notre Dame,
not only beat the Michigan team, but dashed
some of Michigan’s greatest hopes and shattered
Michigan’s fairest dreams.
In the end, whether Batchelor really overheard
such an exchange; came up with the nickname
himself; or, perhaps more likely given he
uses the nickname casually as if the reader
should know exactly who he’s talking about,
had heard it elsewhere, the generally accepted
genesis of the name lies in the previously
mentioned popular association between Catholics
and the Irish.
Given Notre Dame had around this time gone
by the “Catholics,” among other monikers
like the “Terriers,” (with an Irish Terrier
during this time supposedly a staple on the
sidelines), it’s perhaps not much of a leap
to see how someone, perhaps Batchelor, perhaps
not, could have made the jump to “Irish,”
despite the school’s French origins and
mixed heritage athletes.
This is particularly the case if it was indeed
initially meant as an insult, as it would
seem.
Whatever the case, as you’d expect given
the prejudices of the day, the nickname was
not looked upon favorably by the University
brass.
Besides the fact that it seemingly was originally
meant as an insult, this was a French Catholic
University, not Irish Catholic.
However, a little over a decade after Batchelor’s
article, the President of the University,
Father Bums, stated that even though the moniker
had been “discountenanced by the authorities
of the University,” at this point in time,
its “usage [was] in a playful spirit, no
offense being intended…”
With the nickname firmly embraced, despite
the negative connotations, soon, students,
players, media, and even legendary coach Knute
Rockne were calling their beloved team the
“Fighting Irish.”
Noted Notre Dame alumnus Francis Wallace also
did his part in widely popularizing the moniker,
commonly using it in his 1920s New York Daily
News articles.
With little choice and a nod to the complementary
aspects of the nickname- referring to the
athletes’ never say die spirit and scrappy
determination- University President Rev. Matthew
Walsh adopted “Fighting Irish” as Notre
Dame’s official nickname
in 1927.